動画がいいと思ったらチャンネル登録
よろしくね
それでは会話を始めます皆さん連絡事項は
何がありますか
最近お金なくてまともに飯が食えてない
から
なそうだ
明日は調理で使用することにしたのNHK
は鮭の塩焼きを作るので酒優人は味噌汁を
作るのでネギ味噌豆腐ご飯
豚汁はスイートポテトを作るのでサツマ
イモそれぞれ忘れないようになんで急に
調理実習なんてするんですか自分のご飯は
自分で作るこれが大人用の一歩だ
じゃあみんなで協力して料理を作ってみろ
先生は教えてくれないんですか先生は教え
ませんもしかして先生が作り方わからない
だけじゃないですかうるさい自分たちで
考えて作る
よし気合入れて作るぞよしまずは味噌汁
これ
やNHKというのはネギを綺麗
[音楽]
[拍手]
料理できる男子かっこいい家でよくお
手伝いするかこんなん楽勝だよ
[音楽]
見えないどうしようそうだ
できた
頼んだぞもっと
[音楽]
すごいいつもお手伝いさせてるからこんな
楽勝だよ
[音楽]
一件落着これでございますろうたねところ
で肝心の味噌はやべえ味噌忘れた調理実習
で忘れ物するなんてほんと言うたバカだな
ごめんね
どうしようかな
[音楽]
先生先生はどんな味噌が好きですかそうだ
な先生は好きだし白味噌も好きだけど
やっぱり血糖値が高いから豆味噌も好きか
なぁ
絶品なんだよなぁ
頭おかしいから脳みそも腐ってやがる
[音楽]
味噌汁作れないよ
そうだ確かミスはお米と大豆と塩ででき
てるはず
[音楽]
できた
あとは塩があれば
[音楽]
この次もっと投げるかもっと泣くんだ
を作って白馬のそばにいつまでもいられる
ようにしました
[拍手]
[音楽]
できたこれは熟成させれば
熟成ってどのくらいかかるの今は冬だし
23日ぐらいかな
[音楽]
とりあえず次は鮭の塩焼き作ろう
鮭はちゃんと持ってきたよ
頼んだぞぜんじろう
[音楽]
いらない
今度こそ
サンダルもいらないんで
これは来た
ただいまはいこれ避けすげーよしじゃあ
早速焼こう
あれスイートポテト用に持ってきたさつま
いもがない
ちくしょう見失った
[音楽]
なんかここから臭うぞ
先生何してるんですか
腹が減ったから食ってるだけだ調理実習用
の食材なのに調理実習何の話だ
[音楽]
美味しかった
作ってるんですよ
やばいさっき食べたさつまいものせいで
お腹出る
もう
めちゃくちゃだよ
鮭が塩焼きになってる味噌の熟成されてる
やったこれで食べられるぞ
[拍手]
いただきますいただきます
あそういえば千切りロボットは
まあいっかおいしい
[音楽]
千切りにします
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしく最初は
じゃんけんウルトラまたねチャンネル登録